et tout de suite place à notre second
débat que nous consacrons ce soir à la
politique de santé les annonces de
Gabriel Atal dans son discours de
politique générale ne font pas
l'unanimité dans le monde médical à
l'exception peut-être de l'une d'entre
elles qui concerne la régularisation des
médecins à diplôme étrangers qui font
souvent tourner les l'hôpital on les
appelle les pasus pour praticiens à
diplôme hors Union Européenne il seraiit
entre 4 et 5000 en France Jonathan
duprierier en a rencontré pour nous
reportage
ils sont presque invisibles mais
essentiels à notre système de santé les
Padu ces médecins étrangers diplômés
hors de l'Union Européenne aucun
recensement officiel n'existe mais il
serait plusieurs milliers en France
abdelalim ben Saidi est l'un d'eux
arrivé d'Algérie en 2019 ce jeune
praticien de 31 ans est diabétologue en
île-de-fance ce médecin spécialiste
bardé de diplôme et pourtant payé moitié
moins cher que ses homologues de
l'Hexagone le travail est est éégal sauf
que le statut n'est pas le même le
salaire n'est pas le même
et du coup c'est un peu contraignant
dans la vie de tous les jours ça nous
permet pas d'avancer sur certains PLB
euh alors que les Padu ils sont là pour
assurer la continuité des soins ils se
sont très très bien intégrés dans le
système de santé français si ces
médecins ont fait leur preuve depuis des
années dans leur service leur maintien
dans notre système de santé dépend le
plus souvent de leur réussite à un
concours l'épreuve de vérification des
connaissances dites EVC chapauté par le
ministère de la santé fixe chaque année
un quota de postees disponible pour ces
médecins étrangers une épreuve dont
beaucoup jugent les critères injustes et
opaques alors des numérus closus il y a
des spécialités où on nouvre pas de
postees il y a des spécialités où on
ouvre très peu de postes par rapport au
nombre de médecins étrangers qui
exercent déjà ici rajouter à cela le
fait que les Padu qui travaillent ici il
travaillent 60 à 70 heur par semaine ils
ont pas le temps de préparer un concours
au-delà du concours les situations
cfcayennes ne manquent pas comme celle
de Célestin vivor ce pédiatre originaire
de bamaco exerce au CHU de Cayenne grâce
à une dérogation d'homme Tom il est
médecin de plein exercice en Guyane mais
pas en métropole alors je vous montre ça
c'est ma carte
professionnel de l'Ordre des Médecins en
France qui me qui prouve que je suis je
suis médecin en France avec mon numéro
RPPS c'est la même carte que tous les
médecins français ont mais sauf que
c'est pour un département bien précis et
ce régime dérogatoire des DomTom ne
permet à Célestin que d'exercer jusqu'en
2030 au-delà il devra choisir soit
retourner en métropole au risque de
dégrader son statut soit quitter le
territoire pour le Mali benah en 2030 on
peut me dire bah écoute voilà et c'est
fini il faut il faut voilà il
faut quitter la France et donc j'ai
franchement ce souc làà et tout cette
toute cette années de sacrifice au
service public et après me retrouver
comme
ça c'est vraiment très très triste et
voilà pourquoi nous nous nous nous nous
battons les Padu manifesteront le 15
février prochain au pied du ministère de
la Santé ils porteront leurs
revendication notamment l'intégration
pérenne de ces médecins étrangers à leur
postees les associations du secteur
réclament aussi d'être associé aux
futures négociations avec le
gouvernement alors un reportage de
Jonathan dupriz sur ces pasadu nous y
reviendrons au cours de cette émission
que vaut l'ordonnance du docteur hatal
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir Frédéric bzard vous êtes
professeur d'économie à l' SCP président
de l'Institut de santé auteur de
l'autonomie solidaire en santé publié
chez Michalon j'accueille aussi
Véronique Guillotin bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice RDSE de Meur etosel
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales vous êtes médecin vous
avez exercé à la fois en ville et à
l'hôpital et puis vous présidez la
commission santé solidarité de la région
Grand Est j'accueille aussi Gérard
Raymond bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président de France assaut santé alors
pour expliquer c'est l'organisation qui
représente les les patients et les
usagers les usagers de la santé et les
usagers de la santé voilà et puis nous
accueillerons à partir de de 19h par
écran interposé Jean-Paul amont de la
Fédération des médecins de France qui
nous rejoindra et médecin généraliste il
est président d'honneur de de la FM et
puis bien sûr Émilie zapalski notre
éditorialiste qui reste avec moi jusqu'à
la fin de cette émission alors on va
éplucher les mesures les unes après les
autres parler aussi de ce qui manque
mais commençons par un premier tour de
table est-ce que c'est qu'estce qu'
annonce Gabriel Atal ça vous a paru être
un un un un traitement de choc un remède
ou juste un pansement vonique Gutin moi
je pense que ce sont des petites
annonces pour le moment euh non c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas le remède je
pense qu'il va pouvoir transformer le
système de santé en France parce qu'on
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'il
va falloir faire en fait donc on a
quelques mesures je les ai pas toutes on
va je pense que vous allez nous guider
pour les lister donc il y a des mesures
sur les médecins étrangers je crois il y
a quelques mesures sur les les taxes les
taxes lapins enfin voilà on a quelques
mesures qu'on a déjà d'ailleurs vu qu'on
a déjà traité au Sénat mais bon je je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un
vrai choc de transformation du système
je moi j'ai j'ai le sentiment que on a
plus besoin de faire de texte de loi des
choses comme ça il faut qu'on travaille
sur les territoires aujourd'hui vraiment
et qu'on puisse appliquer toutes ces
choses qui existent et et aussi
patienter parce qu'on va pas on va pas
créer des médecins en quelques années on
a un problème de numérusclosus je pense
qu'il faut aussi aujourd'hui se dire
qu'il faut laisser un peu ce temps-là et
puis mobiliser toutes nos ressources
humaines mais il faut travailler sur les
territoires Frédéric bizarre c'est pas
la refonte en profondeur du système de
santé main de fois promise par le
pouvoir mais après tout est-ce que c'est
pas plus efficace casse des réformes à
petit pas à petite touche j' dire plutôt
qu'un grand plan qu'on a toujours du mal
à pondre et toujours du mal à
appliquer je dois avouer que la lecture
politique du du discours du Premier
ministre sur le plan de la santé est
assez difficile à lire tant les mesures
abordées sont insignifiante c'est gadget
non mais c'est même pas gadget je dis
pas elles ont leur importance et leur
intérêt mais dans comme ça vient d'être
dit dans le schéma général de la crise
du système du besoin de refondation qui
qui a été très bien expliqué d'ailleurs
par le chef de l'État il y a déjà 2 ans
lançant un une une conférence nationale
de refondation bon le diagnostic a été
fait il a été bien fait mais là on et je
sens le Premier ministre très très
friable sur ces questions de santé il
est sorti lorsqu'il a fait sa première
sortie au au CHU de Dijon il a parlé
parce qu'on lui a probablement tendu les
fiches et et parlé de 32 milliards où
tout d'un coup on savait pas très bien
de quoi il savait parler 32 milliards
est-ce que c'est à l'hôpital est-ce que
c'est les nouveaux éta déjà prévu tout
ça n'était que ce qui était prévu dans
la loi de financement de sécurité
sociale donc qui é en partie à l'hôpital
mais aussi pour le reste bref donc mais
encore une fois c'est difficile à lire
mais ce que mon interprétation c'est
plutôt qu'il aimerait bien je dirais se
préoccuper d'autres sujets que que la
santé donc en effet peut-être qu'il faut
aller travailler dans les territoires je
ne pense pas que la santé soit
aujourd'hui dans l'agenda politique de
de Monsieur hatal et on pourrait en
discuter si ça va être tenable parce que
le système va quand même profondément
mal il y a une approche en tout cas qui
semble différente Gérard Raymond c'est
qu'on a l'impression que l'approche de
Gabriel Atal elle est plus sous l'angle
du patient que sous l'angle du
professionnel de santé ça vous pour
sanctionner et pour le culpabiliser
certainement
non non ces mesures voilà ce que voilà
les seules mesures pour les patients
c'est les mesures de de de de taxes ou
de que ce soit les franchises pour le
président de la République et la deuxème
l pour le Premier ministre sur sur les
lapenes d'ailleurs il faudra bien nous
expliquer comment ils vont faire pour on
va y venir pour pour relever cet axe là
non je pense que ces mesures ne sont pas
à la hauteur des enjeux aujourd'hui et
puis encore une fois on confond
allégrément santé et Soins euh donc ce
qui nous importe aujourd'hui c'est une
refondation du système de santé c'est on
a oublié depuis quelques mois de parler
de prévention d'éducation à la santé
comment sur les territoire on on on
apporte une véritable offre aux demandes
et aux besoins populationnels
de sur les bassins de vie ca le
président de la République l'a un peu
évoqué mais mais très rapidement donc on
voit bien que ce sont des mesures
j'allais dire techniques de permettre
effectivement à tous ceux qui professent
aujourd'hui en France d'être régularisé
les médecins d'aller chercher des
médecins je veux bien à l'extérieur pour
qu'ils viennent oui mais tout cela s'il
n'y a pas une véritable
refonte du système de santé avec des
nouvelles missions des nouveaux
engagements et aussi évidemment une
vision du financement de notre
protection sociale et sanitaire dans ce
pays et bien on arrivera j certainement
pas à répondre aux besoins
populationnels au niveau de santé et
souhait alors on va ouvrir un premier
chapitre sur la pénurie de médecin parce
que la France manque de médecin c'est
pas c'est pas une nouveauté en ville à
l'hôpital Gabriel Atal se désole que de
la désertification médicale dans notre
pays la saturation de de nos hôpitaux en
particulier des urgences et lui il
souhaite en fait plus de temps médical
alors comment souhaite faire il explique
que cette majorité a a supprimé le
fameux numérus closus vous savez qui
restreignait le nombre d'étudiants et
donc de futurs médecins mais les effets
tardent à se faire sentir alors avant de
commencer ce débat on va on va essayer
de comprendre pourquoi avec Quentin
calmain cette histoire de numérus closus
annoncé supprimé et puis avec quels
effets de quand d'abord de quand ça
datait le le numérus closus Quentin le
numérus closusus date du début des
années 70 il est institué à la demande
des syndicats de médecins libéraux
historiquement très organisés depuis le
début du 20e siècle face à la forte
augmentation du nombre d'étudiants en
médecine plus 69 % entre 1963 et
1967 la profession c'est ainsi organisé
pour garantir des revenus aux médecins
en tentant de limiter leur nombre le
gouvernement de l'époque et les
gouvernements suivants qui ont réduit
progressivement le numérus closus et ont
aussi vu le moyen de réduire les
dépenses de santé Mathieu c'est cette
logique qui va mener à réduire pendant
des années le numérus closus et
justement comment il a évolué au fil des
décennies voyez ce graphicque de la
direction recherche des études d'évation
et des statistiques pendant les
premières années de sa mise en place
jusqu'en 1977 8500 place environ par an
été offerte pour l'entrée dans les
études de médecine ensuite il a diminué
fortement jusqu'en 1993 où il a atteint
un minimum à 3500 places offertes par an
il a ensuite été fortement réhaussé dans
le but de remplacer les départs à la
retraite des médecins issu du baby boom
la hausse très forte entre 2000 et 2005
s'est ralentie jusqu'au milieu des
années 2010 mais pour repartir ensuite
et atteindre un peu plus de 9300 places
ouvertes en 2020 au moment de sa
suppression mais c'est un peu ce retard
qu'on paye aujourd'hui hein parce que la
fin du numérus closus mais c'est pas un
effet automatique tout de suite oui dans
un oui dans un rapport sénatorial de
2022 c'est ce qui écrit la sénatrice
Catherine Deroche les effet de la
suppression du numérus closus ne se
feront sentir au mieux qu'à partir du
début de la décennie 2030 sans garantie
de répartition équitable sur le
territoire la cause les capacités
d'accueil et des moyens de formation des
étudiants sont contraint et vont
progresser lentement ainsi le nombre de
médecins en France va continuer à
diminuer Mathieu entre 2021 et 2026
passant 95000 à 92300 c'est après 2030
qu'il aurait commencer à augmenter à
nouveau car même si le numérus closus a
été supprimé en 2019 ça signifie pas
pour autant qu'il y a plus du tout de
limitation dans dans dans l'accueil des
étudiant ouai tout à fait le numérus
closus en fait il a été remplacé par un
numérus apertus le nombre de places est
fixé en fonction des besoins de santé du
territoire et aussi du nombre de plac
d'accueil dans les facultés de médecine
c'est ce qui fait dire que le nombre de
médecins formés augmente peu rapidement
dans un rapport d'un député de décembre
dernier on note cette phrase le fait que
la France retrouve seulement le niveau
des personnes formées prévu dans les
années 70 alors que la population
française a gagné 15 millions habitant
entre-temps Mathieu merci beaucoup
Quentin on y voit plus clair Frédéric
bizarre c'est un mauvais moment à passer
le temps que que cette suppression du
numérus closusus out ce remplacement
produisent tous ces effets du strict
point de vue de la pénurie de médecin
non mais honnêtement la la la façon avec
laquelle on gère la démographie médicale
ça a été très bien expliqué depuis 50
ans et pas sérieuse d'abord on a pris
cette population médicale comme une
variable d'ajustement pensait-on des
dépenses pensant que l'offre créant la
demande ce qui n'est pas en plus
on réduit le nombre de médecin c'est
vrai avec l'appui d'un certain nombre de
d'une partie de la communauté médicale
pensant que ça
aller protéger un petit peu leur
communauté s'ils étaient moins nombreux
protéger leur revenus et maintenant on
ouvre sans se préoccuper de réellement
des des des besoins qu'il y a partons
des besoins vous savez la santé publique
c'est quand même une science sur
lequelle on a beaucoup progresser sur un
plan scientifique nous sommes
parfaitement capables d'évaluer les
besoins de santé publique pour les 30
ans qui viennent comme on est
parfaitement capable d'évaluer
l'évolution de la démographie pour les
30 ans qui viennent on pourrait faire
peut-être ce travail pour déjà partir
des besoins en matière de médecin des
besoins en fonction des spécialités de
médecin mais c'est pas du tout ça fait
c'est pas du tout comme ça que c'est
fait vous savez qu'elle est il a été
assez généreux votre collègue parce
qu'il a dit en effet à partir des
capacités des universités notamment des
capacités de d'accueil des étudiants et
des budgets des universités et et il a
précisé aussi en fonction des besoins
non en fait on parle pas en fonction des
besoins c'est uniquement en fonction des
capacités nom de place dans les ENF mais
mais bien sûr que c'est comme ça donc
franchement c'est enfin moi je je suis
stupéfait vous savez c'est la ressource
la plus rare dans un système de santé la
ressource humaine c'est la ressource la
plus longue qui est le qui est longue à
former c'est la ressource la plus rare
et franchement ça montre quand même
qu'on est quand même resté sur un un
ministère de la Santé qui est un
ministère très administratif qui fait
pas beaucoup de science et qui pilote ça
comme on pilote ça il y il y a 30 ans
c'est assez inquiétant alors pendant ce
ce creux ce manque de médecin Gabriel
Atal annoncé des solutions à mettre en
œuvre tout de suite selon lui on
l'écoute comme l'a annoncé le président
de la République nous procéderons à la
régularisation des médecins étrangers
sur notre
territoire c'est pourquoi aussi je vous
l'annonce je nom erit un émissaire
chargé d'aller chercher à l'étranger des
médecins qui voudrai venir exercer en
France et nous devons trouver les moyens
de faire revenir nos jeunes Français qui
sont partis étudier à
l'étranger bonsoir Jean-Paul amont
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre je le
disais vous êtes président d'honneur de
de de la de la FM pardon de la FMF je
vais y arriver voilà régulariser les
médecins étrangers qui participent
pour faire tourner notre notre système
de soins c'est une bonne idée selon vous
on ben c'est c'est surtout c'est surtout
un effet d'annonce en fait surtout il
voulait il voulait aller chercher des
médecins à l'étranger c'est surtout ça
qui nous a choqué parce que ça avait
quand même des relants de de
colonialisme aller les chercher dans des
pays où justement on en manque notamment
au Maghreb et en Afrique noir parce que
c'est génébr là que que les gens vont
vont être recrutés alors al que il y a
moyen de de de recruter des des jeunes
médecins vous savez on a on a donné une
die année de de de médecine une deè
année d'études aux seuls étudiants aux
seuls internes en médecine
générale depuis maintenant 2 ans et et
si on permettait à ces médecins qui ne
sont pas concernés par cette 10e année
ceux qui sont en 3e cycle actuellement
de de consulter dans de bonnes
conditions c'est-à-dire que on
doublerait leur salaire on le
permettrait de travailler avec un
secrétariat présentiel avec des maîtres
de stage qui seraient présent au
téléphone ou joignable et qu'on loge ces
ces jeunes médecins on pourrait recruter
1500 médecins formés en France
immédiatement et ça coûterait et ça
coûterait la modique somme de 60
millions d'euros pour 1500 médecins
supplémentaires mais ça il en a pas été
question parce que ce que vous dites
c'est qu'en gros pour régler nos
problèmes de démographie médicale ben on
va en créer chez les autres ce qui c'est
la situation qui était qui était prenée
par par Gabriel Atal il y a une autre
solution qu'il a prené c'était de
permettre aux étudiants français cette
fois-ci oui qui sont à l'étranger qui
sont partis faire leurs études en en
Roumanie en en Hongrie en Croatie de
revenir c'est ça sur sur sur le
territoire Vern Guillotin c'est ce que
j'ai entendu oui moi moi je on a on a
des gens échoué c'est des gens qui ont
pas pu rentrer chez nous mais oui je
veux dire on a c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas pu rentrer dans dans une filière
française et du coup qui sont partis en
Roumanie faire leurs études et qui vont
revenir ou pas enfin après moi je suis
quelqu'un qui pense qu'il faut laisser
la liberté de choix aux gens donc s'ils
veulent rester en Roumanie il resteront
en Roumanie ils ont fait leurs études
là-haut moi moi je suis une frontalière
avec le Luxembourg quand j'entends quand
j'entends la la la discussion sur le
fait d'aller chercher par des médecins
étrangers nous sur le territoire Nord 54
et Nord moselland on se plain je dis pas
tous les jours mais quasiment tous les
jours du pays voisin qui est le
Luxembourg qui attire nos soignants nos
infirmières que nous formons et on ferme
des services entiers parce qu'on a un
problème de recrutement d'infirmièrees
lié à un différentiel salarial important
peut-être moins chez les médecins mais
en tout cas on a cette problématique là
et et certains politiques français
demandent une rétrocession fiscale au
Luxembourg en disant B on les forme mais
il y a pas de raison qu'ils aillent
enfin qu'ils partent au Luxembourg nous
on veut aussi payer cette formation et
en fait je pense qu'on est un petit peu
en train de faire ça moi je pense que le
problème il est pas là on a des
étudiants qui qui font ça par passion
quand même il faut quand même leur dire
c'est des c'est 10 années d'études
aujourd'hui on est passé de 9 à 10 ans
on va voir un bataillon de médecins
généralistes de de docteur junior qui
vont sortir et qui vont pouvoir aller
sur les territoires aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on anticipe on a 2 ans pour les
anticiper ou un an il va falloir que sur
ces territoires on ait des maisons de
santé qui les accueillent parce que les
jeunes aujourd'hui veulent travailler en
exercice coordonné il faut qu'ils aient
un salaire correct pour redonner de la
motivation à ce métier il faut qu'ils
ait des conditions d'un écosystème sur
les territoires intéressants du du
logement également parce
qu'effectivement on a des territoires on
est dépourvu de logement et il faut
qu'on redonne envie à à nos à nos jeunes
de de refaire ces études médicales il
faut un choc d'attractivité et il faut
leur ouvrir la porte de nos universités
et de nos terrains de stage enfin moi je
je pense que la problématique
aujourd'hui elle est sur ce choc
d'attractivité il faut arrêter tout le
temps de charger voilà d'aller chercher
peut-être des des petites solutions
épisodiques ailleurs autre solution
proposé par par Gabriel Atal c'est en
gros de permettre aux autres
professionnels de santé qui ne sont pas
médecins de le devenir en leur
facilitant la vie on écoute le Premier
ministre nous devons aussi nous devons
aussi et c'est ce qu'a proposé le député
Neer mieux reconnaître l'expertise et la
volonté de soignants qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études et qui ont une vraie
expérience une infirmière anesthésiste
qui a un bac + 5 plusieurs années de
carrière et d'expérience elle doit
pouvoir si elle le souhaite rentrer
directement au moins en 3è année de
médecine pour devenir médecin si elle le
souhaite alors je repasse la parole à un
médecin encore une fois Jean-Paul amont
ça ça a fait réagir quand même bah ça a
surtout fait réagir mon interne qui
vient qui vient de quitter ma
consultation en disant euh c'est pas
c'est pas les mêmes études par contre
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui et ça a
été le cas j'ai vu un jeune étudiant qui
a échoué au premier concours et qui fait
une filière scientifique donc il va il
va se taper un master sur sur 4 ans et
lui il aura le droit à une passerelle
s'il est s'il est motivé pour continuer
donc clairement il y a il y a des
solutions il y a il y a des passerelles
et puis quand j'entendais aussi Gabriel
Atal dire qu'il fallait faire revenir
les médecins vous savez le médecin qui
est allé passer sa médecine en Roumanie
il a qu'une chose hein c'est c'est de
rentrer en France parce que c'est pas
par hasard si on a des médecins roumains
qui viennent qui viennent en France
justement parce que bien que nous on on
se plaigne des conditions dans lesquels
on est avec lesquels on est traité
depuis une trentaine d'années et
notamment depuis 6 ans euh les
conditions en rouanie sont quand même
nettement moins favorables qu'en France
donc on a aucun souci pour voir revenir
les médecins je je voyais la signatrice
qui disait effectivement le Luxembourg
est beaucoup plus attractif faisons en
sorte faisons en sorte que la l'exercice
médical soit de nouveau attractif et et
les médecins ne fuiront pas faisons en
sorte que les gens motivés puissent
aller au bout de leurs études faisons en
sorte que les internes ne se suicident
pas euh tous les 18 jours un interne qui
suicide tous les 18 jours comme c'est le
cas actuellement faisons en sorte que
l'État ne poursuive pas les médecins
généralistes parce que soit-disant que
ce sont eux les responsables des des
arrêts de travail donc si vous voulez là
actuellement les les médecins sont
extrêmement inquiets de la façon dont on
les traite euh depuis maintenant 6 ans
quand vous pensez que on est en train de
déployer les télécabines et qu'il est
question de les mettre dans les gares
euh qu'il est question de démanteler
l'exercice médical en le faisant exercer
par des pharmaciens par des kinés par
des infirmières ou par des télécabines
je peux vous dire je serai jeune médecin
j'hésiterai vraiment beaucoup à
m'installer dans les conditions
actuelles alors on en a dit un mot les
les les déserts médicaux hein je
rappelle qu' un rapport sénatorial de de
de mars 2022 dis que 30 % de la
population française en gros vivait dans
un désert médical c'est aujourd'hui
certainement plus he beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui on a quasiment l'emble du
territoire qui qui est dans qui est dans
un désert médical
mais 98 % à part peut-être la Côte
d'Azur et la côte Atlantique où encore
on trouve un pourcentage super mais la
question je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec le docteur Ramon il le sait très
bien mais là je je la la question c'est
l'organisation aujourd'hui et donc
l'organisation des études euh
fondamentales des des des professionnels
de santé on va on leur fait faire
aujourd'hui 10 ans il faudrait peut-être
sur ces 10 ans-là leur donner beaucoup
plus de travaux pratiques d'aller sur le
terrain avec des maîtres de stage de pas
attendre les deux dernières années mais
beaucoup plusut tôt pour qu'ils aient
une véritable compréhension de ce que
c'est le nouveau métier de médecin qui
n'est plus certainement plus le même que
celui qui avait et qui existe encore
demain le médecin sera celui qui sera un
animateur d'équipe qui pour sera là pour
effectivement euh accompagner une équipe
accompagner des malades avoir une
responsabilité aussi euh de santé
publique sur un territoire euh pour
faire de l'éducation à la santé pour
faire de la prévention pour suivre les
pathologies chroniques et cetera donc on
voit bien que il y a une une refondation
totale du métier du médecin qui faut
mettre en place dans dans les formations
initiales et aussi dans les dans les
dans les formations pratiques et donc on
voit bien aujourd'hui que on pourra
aller chercher des médecins à l'étranger
on pourra aller chercher permettre à
certains filières de rattraper si on ne
refonde pas l'organisation sur les
territoires et le rôle de l'ensemble des
acteurs pourir répondre aux besoins
populationnels on restera toujours dans
des difficultés d'offre par rapport à la
demande alors il y a la question de
l'organisation des soins à l'échelle du
territoire qui est qui est importante
aussi parmi les mesures annoncées par
Gabriel Atal le gouvernement a commencé
à mettre en œuvre des services d'accès
aux soins je sais pas si on dit SAS ou
SAS SAS voilà c'est un dispositif que le
premier ministre entend généraliser on
écoute dès cet été chaque département
devra être doté d'un service d'accès aux
soins avec des professionnels organisés
pour assurer la permanence des soins
dans les départements où il n'y aurait
toujours pas de service d'accès aux
soins et de réponses satisfaisantes je
suis prêt à aller plus loin en
restaurant obligations de garde pour les
médecins libéraux en soirée ou le
weekend dans leur cabinet à l'hôpital ou
en maison de santé alors on va on va
prendre les choses dans l'ordre d'abord
le sas Frédéric bizarre c'est quoi le
sas est-ce que ça marche et est-ce que
c'est ça qui va résoudre la crise des
urgences par exemple bah écoutez c'est
c'est une organisation de la permanence
des soins pour s'assurer qu'à tout
moment de de la journée en particulier
de la nuit vous vous puissiez trouver un
médecin je crois que c'est aujourd'hui
dans 70 % des territoires et il le faut
bon mais enfin moi quand j'entends ça du
Premier ministre enfin c'est de tout ce
dont on discute là il y a pas un seul
sujet qui est du niveau pour moi du
Premier ministre est-ce qu'on peut
parler du service public territorial
est-ce qu'on pourrait parler de l'avenir
de l'hôpital public est-ce qu'on
pourrait parler de l'avenir des
biothérapie en France de la de la
recherche de la production enfin il y a
tellement de sujets je vais répondre
mais j'entendaisine vain qui disait que
le ça c'était le 15 en fait
c'étaità donc donc si vous voulez moi je
veux bien que le premier ministre
s'occupe de l'organisation de la
permanence des soins dans les terr toi
mais croyez-moi je sais c'est à peine du
niveau de la ministre laissons ça on a
quand même mis des agences régionales de
santé qui nous coûtent un milliard par
an qui sont avec des dizaines de
milliers de bon enfin peut-être que bon
mais le problème c'est c'est comme la
démographie médicale parce que il faut
quand même essayer d'aborder les les les
vrais sujets on a une chance en France
par exemple pour la démographie médicale
c'est que les études de santé sont parmi
les plus populaires vous savez qu'il y a
je crois que c'est un une demande sur
quatre de parcours sub c'est dans les
parcours de santé donc croyez-moi
quantitatif ement on va pas manquer dans
les années qui viennent il y a il y a
des candidats et comme le disait très
bien Jean-Paul amamont on est
aujourd'hui à à presque 9000 médecins
qui sortent chaque année parce qu' on a
quand même ouvert depuis un certain
temps vous savez c'est juste le
thermomètre le numérus apertus numérus
closus numérus closus si vous le mettez
à 15000 il y a pas de problème donc en
fait on a ouvert mais ça ne change
strictement rien puisque c'est limité
par la capacité de pouvoir former les
gens donc je suis désolé de dire que ça
ne change strictement rien c'est une
décision de l'état de fixer les choses
bon donc donc moi je pense pas qu'il y a
de problème quantitatifs on est
aujourd'hui à une densité à peu près
3,2 médecins par par pour 1000 habitants
on était à 3,3 il y a 10 ans les
Allemands sont un peu plus haut les les
Espagnols les Italiens sont plus bas bon
mais c'est pas ça fondamentalement le
problème le problème c'est les
conditions de travail c'est
l'environnement c'est l'attractivité du
système de soins dans les territoire
c'est tout ça qu'il faut revoir donc au
sein de l'Institut santé on a proposé un
certain nombre de choses dont la
réorganisation d'un service public
territorial qui soit piloté à l'échelle
de territoire définissons déjà des vrais
territoires de santé vous savez que vous
avez autant de territoires de santé que
de secteur vous avez des groupements
hospitaliers territoire qui qui sont une
une unité géographique pour les hôpitaux
non mais pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est
que ça c'est la responsabilité de l'État
c'est que la simplification
administrative elle doit passer aussi
par le millefeuille de de la santé oui
mais justement la simplification
administrative ça veut dire que tout le
monde le même territoire cette approche
populationnelle et préventive qui est
qui qui est qui est mis en avant à juste
titre par Gérard rmon ça c'est essentiel
on est tous d'accord qu'il faut aller
là-dessus la question c'est comment on
le fait et là il faut que l'État impulse
il a juste à impulser et ça il y a pas
de fond supplémentaire à mtre c'est à
impulser comme Napoléon l'a fait il y a
200 ans où il a voulu organiser
l'administration de l'État où on a
défini des départements où on a dit ça
sera la capacité des gens à pouvoir
circuler à cheval sur une une journée il
faut être imaginatif et que l'État dise
voilà votre unité géographique à
l'intérieur de de laquelle vous allez
m'organiser un service public
c'est-à-dire un accès et pas simplement
du soin un service public de la santé ce
qu'on appelleche la santé globale voilà
et moi l'état je vais déterminer ça en
revanche je vous laisse organiser la
permanence des soins le machin parce que
c'est pas à moi à l'état d'aller vous
dire ce que vous devez faire alors
justement sur l'obligation on le voit
bien on va faire réagir les médecins
autour de de de ce plateau mais Émilie
on le sait c'est toujours compliqué pour
les politiques d'obliger les médecins à
faire quelque chose oui et pourtant
c'est une des pistes qui a été envisagé
par Gabriel Atal il en a parlé donc dans
son discours de politique générale on
l'a entendu hein je n'ai pas de tabou et
des obligations de garde pour les
médecins libéraux pourraient être décid
alors pour mémoire cette obligation elle
a été retirée en 2002 à la suite d'un
mouvement de grève elle a été remplacée
par un système collectif basé sur le
volontariat rémunéré au forfait on parle
de la permanence des soins ambulatoires
la PDSA et le système fonctionne plutôt
bien si on en croit le rapport de
l'ordre des médecins alors il y a que 40
% des médecins qui participent mais le
système couvre plus de 90 % du
territoire national c'est risqué pour
pour gabrielal ah ben c'est un peu
risqué parce que le corps médical il est
déjà fortement mobilisé pour une
augmentation des tarifs on sait que la
consultation est passée de 25 à 26,50 €
seulement en novembre il y a eu des
manifestations demand 30 il demande 30
même on entend 50 hein il y a eu des
manifestations fin décembre et début
janvier à ce sujet les médecins sont
donné rendez-vous aussi le 14 février
devant le Sénat parce qu'il y a une
proposition de loi sur l'accès aux soins
qui va être étudiée avec un un
amendement sur les gardes justement
ensuite la mesure pourrait encore
freiner les ardeurs des jeunes médecins
vous dites ils sont réticents ils sont
aujourd'hui que 12 % à choisir cette
voix de médecin libéral et Macron est
sensible à cet argument de
l'attractivité du métier les conditions
de travail on en parlait HE sont très
difficile on parle de 55 heures par
semaine en moyenne 1100 patients suivis
par M mcin et bien sûr ils ont pas de
repos quand ils font une garde et on
sait que le Président de la République
lui il a aussi renoncé à l'obligation
d'installation dansoui pour les jeunes
médecins il y avait pensé puis
finalement il a il y a renoncé ça
faisait partie de son programme de 2022
l'idée a vite était mise de côté
confirmation dans sa conférence de
presse du 16 janvier dernier alors
est-ce que la contrainte c'est la bonne
solution ma réponse est NON je vous
parle je suis d'une famille de médecins
je suis le seul mauais élèves de ma
famille qui n''est pas fait
ça quel est le problème aussi qu'on a
pourquoi on n pas assez d'offre de soins
parce que les médecins qui font plus de
10 ans d'études ils vous disent à juste
titre quand ils finissent vous me posez
des contraintes pour la convention pas
la convention en fait j'ai contribué à
l'effort national j'ai fait tourner
l'hôpital comme externe et comme interne
ce qui est vrai dans notre système vous
allez pas me dire que je vais
m'installer là ou là parce que qu'est-ce
qui va se passer je vous le signe il
quitteront et le président plaide
davantage pour la coordination entre
médecin de ville et hôpital et du coup
l'obligation de de de garde ce tabou il
sera levé B on sait pas trop rien n'est
moins sûr parce que la mesure est
soutenue par contre par 8 Français sur
10 le gouvernement est quand même
soucieux de faire taire les colères on
l'a vu avec la crise agricole la grogne
agricole il a cédé quand même à une
majorité des demandes des agriculteurs
on verra ce qu'il fait avec la grogne
des médecins Jean-Paul amont les
obligations de garde pour les médecins
libéraux dans certains
territoires quand quand j'ai entendu ça
si vous voulez ça m'a fait marrer parce
que franchement euh moi je suis en train
de monter une deuxième maison médicale
de garde sur clamar euh et je peux vous
dire que l'agence régionale de santé ne
nous aide pas beaucoup euh ils ont
commencé par réduire le budget de de 20
% d'une part et au jour d'aujourd'hui
alors que la maison est ouverte depuis
le 1er janvier et qu'on fonctionne
j'attends encore le premier versement de
l'agence régionale sanitaire alors que
j'ai dû payer les secrétaires payer le
matériel euh et et et tout ça est bien
énervant on m'apprend aujourd'hui que
pour faire un virement de de la RS il
faut 7 jours imaginez-vous quand vous
faites un virement d'un compte à compte
7 jours pour la RS ça ça ça ça fait
rêver donc j'aimerais bien que le
ministre j'aimerais bien j'aurais bien
aimé entendre monsieur hatal parler
d'organisation des soins faire en sorte
que l'accès à l'hôpital soit régulé
donner les moyens à la médecine de ville
d'éviter les hospitalisations et de les
raccourcir quand vous pensez que un un
infirmier
qui permet de maintenir à domicile des
personnes âgées avec le médecin
généraliste son déplacement est passé de
2,50 € à
2,75 comment voulez-vous maintenir des
gens à domicile maintenir des motiver
des infirmiers dans ces conditionslà il
faut éduquer effectivement les la la
population au bon usage de l'hôpital il
faut organiser les soins il faut
permettre à la ville d'éviter les
hospitalisation et ça et ça c'est
capital et ça on l'a pas entendu dans un
discours de politique générale on l'a
pas entendu et c'est bien dommage parce
que l'obligation d'installation euh
monsieur Macron l'a enfin compris mais
ce qu'il n'a pas compris c'était la
dureté du métier de médecin parce que je
l'ai entendu à cet avou euh dire que le
métier de médecin c'éit un métier dur à
cause du nombre d'heures or j'attendais
la suite à aucun moment il a parlé du
contact avec la maladie avec la mort
avec la fragilité de l'existence et ça
j'aurais bien aimé l'entendre de la
parole du président de la République ce
serait bien qu'on arrête de penser les
médecins comme des générateurs de
dépenses mais comme des générateurs de
soins j'entends j'entends Monsieur
Raymond dire qu'il est pas souvent
d'accord avec moi on parle de prévention
mais il n'y a plus de médecins scolair
on parle de prévention mais il y a plus
de médecin du travail pour aller
vérifier les conditions d'exercice des
salariés au sein de l'entreprise et
c'est pas parce que vous allez faire
pipi dans un bocal devant une infirmière
du travail tous les 3 ans que c'est une
médecine du travail personne ne va
vérifier les conditions d'exercice des
salariés au sein de l'entreprise et
quand il y a des arrêts de travail les
seuls responsables ce sont les médecins
généralistes bien entendu parce que ce
sont eux les responsables de tout ces
feignants qui veulent pas s'installer
donc si vous voulez quand la liberté
d'installation si vous voulez comment
voulez-vous toucher à la liberté
d'installation quand la France entière
est un désert quand la France entière
est un désert on a bien compris que on a
bien compris que ça ne nous avait pas
convaincu jeanp je reprends la main
parce qu'on a encore un autre sujet à
aborderage quelqu'un qui est depuis 50
ans sur le terrain médecin généralist
connaut rouver du temps médical pour
Gabriel Atal c'est de responsabiliser
les patients notamment en luttant contre
le phénomène des rendez-vous non honoré
non honoré c'est ce qu' la fameuse taxe
lapin alors c'était une idée au départ
portée par une sénatrice LR Corine
Bert on écoute le Premier ministre il y
a encore aujourd'hui trop de rendez-vous
médicaux qui ne sont pas honorés pour
les médecins il est insupportable
d'avoir chaque jour des patients qui ont
un rendez-vous et qui ne se présentent
pas pour les Français il est
insupportable de savoir que des millions
d'heures sont perdus alors qu'ils
attendent parfois des mois pour un
rendez-vous je souhaite un principe
simple qui se traduise par des mesures
claires dès cette année quand on a
rendez-vous chez le médecin et qu'on ne
vient pas sans prévenir on paye alors
Gon je vous vois
bouillir sur cette affaire frapper le
patient porte-monnaie c'est pas la bonne
solution je ne vais pas m'inquiéter
comme comme Jean-Paul mais oui oui non
c'est pas sérieux c'est d'abord pas
sérieux parce que on nous annonce des
chiffres extraordinaires de de
rendez-vous non 27 millions de
rendez-vous n l'ordre des médein cette
affaire là ça fait quand même une bonne
année que ça que ça que ça dure et donc
nous-même avons pris contact avec des
plateformes de de prise de rendez-vous
avons pris contact aussi avec des
syndicats de médecins et libéraux pour
réfléchir et travailler et les chiffres
que nous présentent les plateformes ne
sont pas cux donc c'est beaucoup moins
important et ensuite on voit bien
qu'effectivement parfois les
professionnels de santé nous disent ben
si un rendez-vous non ononurit ça me
Perm Peret de rentrer mon dossier ça me
permet de rentrer dans mon espace et
cetera et cetera donc faut faut faut
faut raisong garder la deuxième chose
c'est qu'encore une fois de plus on
trouve bien la solution pour
responsabiliser les citoyens à ce bien
de consommation qui qui est le système
de santé qui n'est pas du tout un bien
de consommation il faudrait peut-être le
regarder totalement différemment bien
voilà on va les faire payer je je tiens
à dire que dans le Code de Santé
publique et jean-pa le sait très bien on
ne peut pas a touché une rémunération
quand on l'a pas effectué c'est pasg M
la consultation la consultation on peut
pas donc qui va qui va récupérer cette
cette amende comment elle va être
récupérée est-ce que c'est l'assurance
maladie est-ce que c'est la la
plateforme enfin tout ça nous intéresse
de voir comment donc c'est plutôt la
faisabilité ou c'est sur le principe que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord que c'est
plutôt dans la culpabilisation on va
culpabiliser les gens pourquoi mais il
faudrait peut-être aussi s'interroger
sur la cause pourquoi il y a autant je
veux bien de rendez-vous non honorés
c'est parce que Jean-Paul le sait très
bien il nous faut 7 jours pour avoir un
rendez-vous avec notre médecin
généraliste peut-être qu'en 7 jours on
aura trouvé une solution où on aura vu
voilà un pharmacien ou autre et on se
sera il nous faut plusieurs mois pour
avoir un rendez-vous avec un spécialiste
d'ici là peut-être on a trouvé notre
solution les uron ça n'empêche pas
d'aller décommander le le rendez-vous un
peu plus loin qu'on pris ça fait partie
de la responsabilité ça fait
é citoyenne je pense qu'aujourd'hui
aussi on est rentré dans une are où
effectivement il faudrait peut-être
acculturer l'ensemble de no concitoyens
et notre part de responsabilité du
milieu associatif et là aussi engagé
c'est responsabiliser les gens à user du
système et ne pas en abuser et donc et
de rester respectueux qu on a vu une
campagne sur la maltêtrance des
professionnels de santé on peut aussi
peut-être faire une campagne sur la
maltraitance aussi des patients qui
attendent plusieurs heures sur des
chariots qui attendent plusieurs heures
dans une salle d'attente je veux pas
rentrer dans ce débat là parce qu'il est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux
aujourd'hui de laondation du système de
S pour comprendre Véronique guillottin
c'est faisable c'est pas faisable je
pense je pense que ça c'est moi je vois
pas comment en pratique c'est faisable
moi je cet amendement cet amendement a
été déposé au Sénat en fait donc moi
j'ai sur le fond de la
responsabilisation des uns et des autres
de pouvoir prendre son téléphone de
décommander un rendez-vous d'avoir des
multiplications de rendez-vous non
honoré je pense que effectivement voilà
c'est compliqué alors la médecine n'est
pas le restaurant mais de toute façon
c'est dans tous les domaines de de dans
tous les domaines d'activités où c'est
comme ça et je pense qu'effectivement il
faut se pencher sur ce problème là
certains professionnels de santé le
gèrent dans leur cabiné hein je je suis
pas sûr que ce soit du niveau d'une loi
d'un texte machin mais il faut il faut
quand même pas se dire que c'est rien
parce que quand on a des des rendez-vous
successifs quon est dans un cabinet
médical enfin voilà et que ça on peut
faire effectivement autre chose mais bon
quand même il faut pas non plus dire que
c'est complètement normal et que le
médecin a autre chose à faire d'avoir
trois rendez-vous qui se décommandent
mais je pense qu'il faut effecent se
mettre autour de la table voir comment
c'est réalisable je je vois pas trop
cette histoire d'amande mais il faut
mais je sais pas si ce sujet là c'est
get c'est marginal enfin je veux dire ça
doit être résolu oui sur le territoire
faut se poser faut savoir comment on va
le faire mais c'est pas prier
minist a un sujet qui a pas abordé
gabrielal c'est le médicament pas un
mot grand
sujet mé n' pas été abordé mais encore
une fois moi je crois que quand
comme ça
DESS faire diversion on en discute ce
soir je ne sais pas essayer de je suis
assez d'accord que Y a c'est assez
dangereux parce qu'on a toujours
l'impression un peu de culpabiliser un
jour c'est le médecin un autre jour
c'est le patient un are jour le truc
donc c'est à mon avis assez dangereux
mais il y a quand même une façon il y a
pas que le premier ministre président de
la République moi je suis quand même
abassourdi de la façon avec laquelle on
fait de la politique de santé dans ce
pays quoi vous prenez ce sujet moi j'ai
un petit peu regardé avant de venir pour
avoir moi je sais pas quand je travaille
sur un sujet je j'essaie d'avoir des
données j'essaie d'avoir du fond vous
voyez il y a rien il y a pas une seule
étude qui a été faite il y a rien sur la
tax lapin sur la tax lapin il y a rien
et on alors il y a une étude qui a été
faite par MG je les cite qui ont
interrogé un millier de leur médecins
généraliste juste non mais je vous dis
juste parce qu'elle est drôle quand même
un/ers des médecins généralistes
interrogés trouve que c'est un problème
insupportable un autre tiers est ravi de
cette respiration qui permet de se
détendre ou de rattraper son retard et
enfin un ti ne s'en préocupe pas et donc
le Premier ministre le président de la
République prennent la parole sur un
sujet qui n'a pas du tout été réfléchi
sur le fond par le ministère franchement
c'est extrêmement inquiétant de ce
qu'est devenu ce ministère de la Santé
où on aimession d'une coquille
complètement vide je rappelle qu'heure
où nous parlons on a toujours pas minist
professionnels de santé depuis bien
longtemps gérer le problème des des
retards hein moi je les cabinets
dentaires sont beaucoup plus strictes
sur les horaires les
les quand même symptomatique de la
stratégie de Gabriel il a fait pareil au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
plutôt que de s'attaquer au problèmes de
fond avoir ce modèle essayer de voir
l'attractivité l'organisation on balance
des mesures comme l'uniforme la BAA qui
font un peu pas diversion parce que
c'est quand même utile mais c'est quand
même une petite chose un peu plus
anecdotique que bah le fond de l'iceberg
qui est quand même beaucoup plus énorme
et auquel il ne s'attaque pas maintenant
sur ce sujet il serait intéressant
d'essayer de de de s'interroger si ce
phénomène existe et si beaucoup de
médecins le ressentent donc c'est mais
pourquoi alors qu'on a un problème de
pénurie de médecin pourquoi finalement
on se retrouve comme si on avait que
l'embarras du choix pour avoir un
médecin on annule là pour aller ailleurs
alors ce n'est pas le
cas je voudrais la vie de jean-pa àont
pour conclure parce qu'il nous reste 2
minutes d'émission jean-pul sur cette
affaire de tax Lain parz parce que ma
consultation de cet après-midi j'ai une
famille qui avait trois rendez-vous qui
n'est pas venu qui n'a pas prévenu et
donc comme moi j'ai un secrétariat
présidentiel je peux vous dire que il va
falloir qu'ils aient une bonne excuse
parce que ceuxl ils ont ils vont changer
de médecin immédiatement euh on a une
règle dans mon cabinet euh si quelqu'un
nous pose un lapin on le prévient qu'à
trois lapins euh il change de médecin
traitant et et par contre ce qui est en
train de se g ce qui est en train de se
généraliser c'est le développement des
plateformes vous savez euh la plateforme
qui qui fait tout actuellement là euh et
bien qui qui se permet de de de
valoriser des des professions qui sont
même pas des professions de santé parce
qu'ell crachent pas sur un abonnement et
donc vous avez des gogo thérapeutes qui
sont sur doctolib et cetera euh les gens
prenent rende avec un médecin les gens
prennent rendez-vous avec un médecin et
puis il trouent il trouvent deux places
de rendez-vous un peu plus tôt et bien
ils vont voir l'autre médecin et il
n'annulent pas il y a aucune sanction de
la part de la de la plateforme qui se
goinfre et qui est en train de
désorganiser les soin vous savez ça le
développement d'octolip moi quand j'ai
un nouveau patient un nouveau patient il
commence sa consul qui commence par un
lapin celui-là immédiatement il est viré
et il reprend plus jamais rendez-vous
avec moi donc si vous voulez nous quand
on a quand on a une quand on a un
secrétariat présentiel et qu'on a un
informatique qui une informatique qui
fonctionne je peux vous dire les
patients on on évite ces gens qui sont
mal polis mal embouchés et qui n'ont
aucun respect pour les médecins donc
comme ça c'est fait il y a pas besoin de
monter l'usine à
gageab merci beaucoup Jean Palamon tu
casses tu répares tu salives tu lestoit
tu ne viens pas tu reviens plus c'est un
peu ce que ce que pourrait proposer
Gabri responsabilisation des patients
dans notre système de santé c'est un
sujet absolument fondamental et qui qui
donnera lieu à un prochain débat parce
que le temps de ce débat est déjà
terminé merci à tous les quatre d'y
avoir participé merci à vous de l'avoir
regardé vous retrouverez demain dans ce
fauteuil évidemment Thomas HUG et puis
c'est Joë Mergy président du Consistoire
central israélite de Paris est d'Île-de-
France qui sera l'invité de la matinale
de Public Sénat demain
[Musique]
matin